في غضون ذلك اعلنت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه شنت فجر
اليوم هجوما بخمسه عشره مسيره اسقطت
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه احدى عشره
منها وكانت الاداره العسكريه في كييف
اعلنت ان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه تصدت
الليله الماضيه للمسيرات استهدفت العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وضواحيها ودعت السكان للبقاء
في الملاجئ
وعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
اشتبكت مع القوات الروسيه 29 مره في عده
جبهات من مقاطعتي
خيال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه
فقال قالت هيئه الاركان ان قواتها صدت
محاولات تقدم للقوات الروسيه جبهات
الايمان ومخموت
ومارينكا وكوبيانسك
بمقاطعتي دونيسك
واوضحت الهيئه ان المعارك تزامنت مع قصف
مدفعي وغارات جويه مكثفه مشيره الى تنفيذ
قواتها خمسه عشره غاره جويه واكدت اصابه
ثلاثه مراكز تحكم
وعشر وحدات مدفعيه الروسيه
قال موقع ريبار العسكري الروسيه ان قوات
الروسيه اخترقت دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني
شمال شرقي مدينه بمقاطعه دونيتسكو واكد
الموقع ان القوات الاوكرانيه دفعت
بتعزيزات في محاوله للحفاظ على مواقعها في
بلده تورسكوي التي تشهد معارك عنيفه نشر
الموقع العسكري وصورا قال انها لتدمير
اليات عسكريه اوكرانيه خلال محاولاتها
التقدم تجاه مواقع المواقع وتحصينات الجيش
الروسي قرب نهر
بين مقاطاعتي دونيتسك
انضموا الينا من كييف مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود مرحبا بك معنا حسان ونرحب ايضا من
جنوب دونيتس بمراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
مرحبا بكما ابدا معك حسان وما تعلنه هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه عن هذه الهجمات التي
تشنها طبعا في مناطق عده
بعد الحديث عن استهداف العاصمه نفسها
بالمسيرات
نعم محمد بالفعل هي تطورات متزامنه التي
تشهدها الساحه الاوكرانيه سواء كانت عبر
الضربات الجويه بمسيرات انتحاريه تستهدف
مناطق اوكرانيه عده كانت العاصمه ابرز
الوجهات لهذه المسيرات خمسه عشر مسيره
انتحاريه اطلقت نحو اوكرانيا 11 منها
اسقطتها الدفاعات الجويه لاسيما بمحيط
العاصمه الاوكرانيه الا ان منطقه شركاسي
الواقعه وسط اوكرانيا يبدو انها تعرضت
لاستهداف بالمسيرات من بين المسيرات
الاربعه التي لم تستطع الدفاعات الجويه
اسقاطها وفق الروايه الاوكرانيه تقول
الاداره العسكريه
تحتيه وهي عاده ما تشير لمنشات عسكريه
بهذا اللفظ تعرضت للاستهداف دون
الافصاحيه عن واقعي وطبيعه هذه المنشاه
بشكل
واضح انما ايضا اشارت فقط الى اصابه
الشخصين بهذه الضربه هذه الضربات الجويه
تزامنت مع التطورات الميدانيه المتواصله
على طول الجبهات الممتده من اقصى الشرق
الى اقصى الجنوب القوات الاوكرانيه وهيئه
الاركان اشارت الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه
صدت هجمات عند عدد من المحاور يبدو ان
القوات الروسيه كانت تحاول التقدم عبرها
لاسيما شمالي وجنوبي مقاطعه دنياتك عند
منطقه ليمن وكذلك عند تقاطع منطقه
كوبيانس في مقاطعه مع مقاطعه لوغانسك
بالاضافه ايضا الى صدها هجمات كما تقول
عند محور ومانيكا جنوبيه دومياتك الا انها
تشير كذلك الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت
التقدم عند محيطي مدينه باخموت وهي
محاولات مستمره من الجانب الاوكراني لا
سيما عند فيها الجنوبيه الا انها ايضا
اشارت الى انها صدت هجمه روسيه عند الجهه
الشماليه من مدينه باخمت وهذا يشير الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه واثناء قيامها بتنفيذ
هجمات مضاده هي كذلك تدافع
لصدها هجمات اخرى تقوم بها القوات الروسيه
اما عند الجهه والجبهه الجنوبيه والجنوبيه
الشرقيه عند محور زابولوجيا القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول في بيانها ان
القوات الروسيه تحاول منع تقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه عند محور زابولوجيا الا انها
ايضا تشير الى استمرار القصف العنيف
والمكثف بين الجانبين على طول الجبهه لا
سيما عند المناطق الجنوبيه